I put on my orange suit because
somebody's about to walk out here who is
a cultural icon
um but fun fact do you know that she
actually worked as a bricklayer and a
mortuary cosmetologist
[Applause]
hello
hi
I know right oh my God I'm so happy to
see you hello did you put makeup on dead
people yeah oh my God yeah I put stuff
on and you put stuff on and make sure
eyes don't pop open and
did you have to seal them shut yeah in
the old days yeah and that's what they
did you know they ironically something
that is going around I can't even turn
on Instagram or any Outlet I feel like
without hearing about Sister Act three
talk about
like everybody wants it to happen
everybody's asking you cast like Kiki
Palmer obviously everybody wants to be
in it we got we just got the script
on
Friday
actually I'm very very very pleased
whatever's wrong we can fix and I just
want them to give us a go date so you
should let me know if you're in I I will
are you kidding me
why not why not anything are you kidding
no let's have some fun remember that
remember having fun I do remember having
fun I feel like everyone you mentioned
this to they're just immediately on
board you've built this will be the
third the Holy Trinity of Sister Act
three well it's listen you can't go
wrong
with 15 Singing Nuns he's you can't you
know and and there's no reason why I
don't know how many of you remember this
but when I was a kid there was a show
called Batman yes Adam West Adam West
The Fabulous late Adam West yes and they
would be walking up the side of the of
the side of the building and some major
star would open a window and say
something I feel like we can incorporate
that somebody's coming out of the
confessional
maybe dressed as a priest or as a nun
you know any
did you see
in real time my television was on and I
had it on Jennifer Hudson's show yes I
do um and she came out on Halloween yes
as you and sang that song and sang that
song I've made everybody realize oh she
should be a singer
I was like no no no no she's brilliant
but
well and your phone's fabulous he gots
both of you are egot yes yes
now we were looking at your IMDb your
movie credit list there's over 200 oh
credits on there is there anything in
that 200 that you haven't done and
you're dying to do a remake some
character you've never gotten to play
anything that it's like an itch you
haven't scratched yes there's only one
what I really want to play a monster
because who would suspect me foreign
you know I've always wanted to be
vampire or something that was built and
it turned into me and you know because
it's my favorite genre and it's a genre
I've not I've not ever been able to play
in do you see it like a Guillermo del
Toro type of movie if only right please
please okay so the last time you were
here we both were single you weren't
dating are you dating now no I am good
good because this had been so many years
I started to get a little worried well
you know it when it's like I'm too good
at being alone well no no you know what
being alone is not a bad thing I love it
too much well
perhaps if you are not knitting it
together with other stuff you can be
alone and they're not alone
and then alone and then not alone so you
could compartmentalize it a little bit
and run so maybe a hit and run is a
better way to go
for now for now until you're until you
say to yourself you know now I I really
want someone to just be part of this
right now that may not be what you're
looking for which is probably why you're
doing fine so you don't ever get like
itchy to include somebody in the picture
for good no but a hit and run hit and
runs are great
because I do still hit and run all the
time
all the time
now here's what's going to happen
now that I've said this to you that's
all I'm gonna say
Who is the one people are going to try
to figure it out you can't
you can't figure it out because I made a
made it a point to make sure that that
was mine
I didn't want to share it you know I
don't want it to be part of other
people's humor stories about me uh hit
and run
I almost didn't think I know you did
[Music]